Let's take a look at what we used to believe and then contrast it to what we now know.
One of the biggest fallacies was believing that startups
are just smaller versions of a large company.
That everything you do in a large company, you'll do on day one of a startup.
What we now know is something very different.
The core difference is that startups do something called search
while large companies spend their time, at least their core time, executing.
One of the questions we'll answer is search for what and execute what.
And so later on in this lecture, you'll see the difference
and then in fact will make you a much better enterpreneur.